hello everyone my name is vaiphoth
saying i'm a machine learning specialist
working with google cloud
and here is i'm thailand i'm a software
engineer
in google cloud working on python tps
and today we are going to talk about
pytorch at scale
on cloud tpus so let's get started
and here is going to be our map for the
talk we're going to start
with an introduction then we'll move to
step-by-step walkthrough of a
example we will discuss how it exactly
works
and how to scale your pytorch training
on cloud tpus
and finally we are going to leave you
with resources
tips and tricks so that you can start to
train your pytorch model
on tpus today pytorch is officially
supported on cloud tpus this support
is made possible through the torch xla
library and open source initiative
from facebook and google it was
announced in october 2019
at pytorch devcon and has been growing
ever since
the support reached beta with pytorch
1.5 release
and would be generally available by the
time you'll be seeing this recording
for those of you who are not very
familiar with tpus
tpu's or tensor processing unit is a
hardware accelerator built by google
in 2015 first to address its own
internal needs
the very first generation of tpus was an
inference only chip
beginning with version 2 it evolved to
support training
as well and beginning with version 2
google also made tpus available to the
rest of the world
through google cloud with the vision to
help push machine learning state of the
art forward
you can scale your machine learning
workloads using tpus from eight cores
all the way to tpu parts tpu parts
consist of thousands of tpu cores as you
can see on the left hand side of your
screen
dpu comes in two different flavors on
google cloud as of today that is tpu v2
and v3
you can start with a device as you can
see on the left hand uh
top corner of your screen all the way to
the full pod
a cloud tpu v2 pod comes with 512 cores
and a cloud tp v3 part comes with 2048
course you can choose
a slice of a pod all the way to the full
pod
for your machine learning trainings here
is a cloud tpu device
uh in order to access this device a user
creates
a vm or a virtual machine on google
cloud and creates an instance of
cloud tpu you can create this instance
in different device types in this case
we are
uh choosing v3 8 that indicates a
v3 device each v38 comes with four chips
each of these chips has got two
cores and each of these scores come
equipped with
matrix multiplication units two matrix
multiplication units
each and 16 gb
of high bandwidth memory per core all in
all this device has got eight cores and
that's why when you choose
the accelerator type when you're
creating this device you choose
v3 8 or v2 8 whereas when you are
working with pod
in case of a cloud tpu v3 uh a full tpu
port consists of 256
tp devices or 2048 cores uh
interconnected with a high speed
interconnect
which lets the uh
the the gradient averaging or all reduce
operation
run very efficiently on the full power
the tpu software stack enables you to
train
all the way from a tp device to the tpu
pod or any intermediate size without any
code changes
and it always acts as a single node
without any complicated cluster setup
now let's take a look into an example
of a python code as we know it and then
see how
how this code needs to be modified or
what are the modifications we typically
see in order to run that by dodge code
on cloud tpus so first of all let's
begin with a familiar territory for
those of you
who are familiar with distributor
training on pytorch
you have already seen similar examples
uh similar elements such as the
pi torch distributed libraries you see
the model
you see the model being transferred to
uh the devices in this case gpu devices
you see the familiar elements like data
loader and
uh distributed sampler the distributed
sampler make sure that each of the
replicas of the model
are actually looking at the different
slices of the data and not
looking at the same slice you see
uh familiar elements like the train data
loader
you see the the forward pass within the
training loop
and the backward pass which computes the
gradient
you see the optimizer step uh that is
uh going to update the parameter based
on the computer gradient
and the optimizer of choice and you
notice
the torch multi-processing spawn method
which
executes this training loop in this
particular example
four different replicas of this model
are running in parallel um
now let's see how this uh this code
changes
when we are going to train it on cloud
tpu device
as i was describing a cloud tp device
consists of four cloud tpu chips
or eight tpu cores beginning with
the elements like torch xla library this
is what makes the training of pytorch
model on tpu possible
similar to what you saw in case of gpu
we have a
we have another device abstraction
called accele device
uh this is an abstraction of cloud tpu
code similar to
how you were transferring your model on
cloud tpu
device you are transferring your uh
model on cloud dp core here and finally
uh the the elements like the
distributed sampler or the data loader
remain exactly the same
with one difference that we are using a
parallel loader which is a wrapper
here that makes sure that the data
upload operations to
2d views are run in parallel with the
computations in order to make the data
pipeline efficient
one more important distinction to
highlight here is that we are using
uh the optimizer step method from xlr
model
module uh instead of optimizer dot step
method that you saw
uh in the previous example this is to
make sure
that the all reduce operation is
performed first
before the optimize dot step is called
to update the parameters
and finally instead of the torch
multiprocessing
module you have xla multiprocessing
uh module which has the similar spawn
method
which under the hood takes care of all
the necessary tpu device initialization
and setup before using the torch
multi-processing module to start again
in a similar fashion uh the processes
running in parallel to facilitate that
training uh
on eight different replica of your model
in this case because we are
running on eight cores and also notice
the start method equal to fork which is
used to
make sure that the model is copied into
the memory only once each of the child
process will be able to use
all the resources are spun up before
that in the global scope
now let's let's look at the live example
of
one of the trainings that we are going
to do
on resnet18 model uh using the cifar10
dataset
so we start with a cloud console
here i have set up a cloudy a platform
notebook
instance with idris xla library and all
the necessary components
ready to go so i start my notebook
instance
in the meantime notice also that i have
created
a cloud tpu instance
that's a b38 device so four
chips eight cores notice the runtime
version that is displayed in this column
whenever you create a
cloudtp device and this is the internal
ip that is used to set up
xrttp config environment variable
before you start the training this is
required for
the user vm or your vm to be able to
communicate
to the tpu instance
so uh we are about to demo
the pi dot resonant 18 model on c410
data set
so as described earlier we start with by
setting the xrdtp config
environment variable this is the ib
address that we noted earlier
so we execute the cell
then define some hyper parameters
then sourcing the libraries there notice
that here we are using the resonant 18
model from
torch vision library then we define our
training loop
notice in the training loop that apart
from the
test loop function apart from the train
loop function that we have seen in
example walk through there
we also have the test loop function
defined for tracking the evaluation
metric and the results
rest of uh the aspect of the code should
look very familiar to you based on the
walkthrough
here is the helper function for plotting
the results
and this is the function that is going
to call the training
method which will have the training loop
function that we saw above
we're using the excel multiprocessing
spawn method here
and we are using the
mp function as one of the argument and
passing passing the other flags
specifying the number of codes and start
method folk
as described in the walkthrough and then
here we start
so as this training is starting to run
we are going to look at one or
another instance of this notebook which
has
this whole training execution finished
and as you would notice that we execute
this training for 20 bucks
it is going to take a few minutes to
finish after
20 box it attains close to 78 79 percent
of accuracy
and you can also notice that it is
possible to track things like images per
second
and other matrix as you would do in a
normal pie dodge code
so here we are getting almost 76 percent
of the accuracy and then
here we are ready to visualize the
results and this is
these are the results here as you can
see that
for most of the examples it was still
working well and there are some error
cases as well since
it only attained about 76 of accuracy
now that you're familiar with torch xla
usage
you may be wondering how exactly it
works
if you're familiar with bytoch tensor
class
or a10 you already know that it extends
support to multiple device
implementations or memory layout through
dynamic dispatches to those
implementations
torch xla extends a-10 with a new type
of tensor called
excellent tensor xlr tensor is different
from
other eager implementations
in that that it's a lazy tensor
while eager tensors are dispatched up by
up
and the only computation graph that is
generated is for
the gradient computation and as soon as
the gradient computation or the backward
pass is done this graph is destroyed
the lazy tensor in case of laser tensor
by torque excellent just constructs
an xla intermediate representation graph
with no evaluation is performed on this
graph until required
either by a certain operation in your
model code itself
or by a call that necessitate the
context transfer from
the tensor to scalar building this
iograph also enables pytorch xla
to do certain graph level optimizations
which are not possible if you are doing
the off by
op dispatch this ir graph is then sent
to tpu device
is then compiled and sent to tp device
for execution
between training steps if the ir graphs
are identical
excellent compilation is not performed
however if i air graph is going to
change too frequently
between training step or because of the
nature of the code itself
every time it changes the excel
compilation needs to be performed
and it might slow down your training to
take more uh details into what are the
things to watch out for and how
you can make the most of your pie dodge
training
here is my colleague talan who will talk
about
tips and tricks all right thanks
swipeoff
um so let me talk
about some of the tips and tricks uh
things to watch out for when you port
your model
from gpu code to tpu code
one of the most common pitfalls is
dynamic input shapes
as weibov noted earlier every time the
intermediate representation graph
changes
this triggers an xla recompilation
and that slows things down and this
happens when
the model has input shapes uh
that change from one step to another
a a good example is an nlp model where
you have sentences
of varying length for example or some
an image model with images changing
shapes
another common pitfall is what we call a
context change between
device to cpu and the most common
occurrence for that is when uh
the code has tensor dot item calls in it
this uh slows things down uh because as
weibov noted earlier xla
is built on a lazy tensor idea
and the item calls prematurely causes
evaluation
and result is suboptimal if that happens
third most common pitfall is uh if the
model code has
uh is using some operation that has no
xla implementation
uh yet uh then uh that
doesn't cause an error but it causes the
iograph to get cut and
the operation that's not lowered to xla
gets executed on the cpu which slows
things down we want to stay in the
device context as much as possible
when that happens these things happen we
have solutions
for example for the first problem
dynamic input shapes
we may use padding we may take the
sentences with varying length and pad it
to a fixed length or
maybe we predetermine three or four
fixed lengths and pad it to the next
length uh and uh in the latter case
we will still have recompilations
because the input shapes will
take three or four different values and
uh
each time the first time they are seen
we're going to compile
but we're going to waste less flops as a
result
of less padding so there's a trade-off
there
second when we have the tensor to scalar
context change or device to cpu context
change
we this can happen because of for
example loss reporting
because losses are usually a tensor what
we do
we recommend to reduce the item calls
and report loss
every n steps instead of maybe every
step
um and can take a value of 20 30 100
that's up to the user uh we the user
could also have item calls
from another part of the model
they need to be spotted and eliminated
uh in the third case
if we encounter an hop with no xla
lowering
we usually just create a github issue
in python github dot com slash python
xla
and ask the torch xla team to lower
this head up uh so that the the
operation runs on the device and is
accelerated as a result
we have talked about uh problems and
solutions but how do you actually
understand what is going on and what the
problem actually is
so this is the slide from earlier we
want to focus
on the white rectangles here we are
importing
torches ladybug metrics here and we are
printing the metrics report
this metrics report contains a lot of
information about what's going on at the
xla level
and it can surface some of the issues
that i just discussed in
in the previous slides and let's look at
an examples metrics report this is
just a summary that focuses on the
issues that we discussed
the actual metrics report contains more
information than just this
if you look at the first part the the
metric compile time this gives us
information about how many graph
recompilations have occurred in this
workload
and in this case we have 202
compilations that occurred and the total
time it took
is six minutes now the metric support is
usually uh
composed of metrics and the counters the
counters
give information about what's happening
in the code
for example the counter mark step uh
tells you that
uh how many training steps
that we have uh we have taken for
example in this case
232 steps have been taken and that
resulted in 202 compilations
which suggests that there's a problem
with uh
the the uh graphs that the code is
generating the compilations should be
uh at low some compilations initially
are okay
but it shouldn't grow as the number of
steps grow
similarly for example in the item call
problem the context switch between
device and cpu the counter atom local
scalar dance will be
will be your friend and here in this
case you have 240
occurrences of that and that's uh
that's something that needs to be
reduced to get optimal performance
in the third problem that we discussed
the op that's not been lowered yet
you will see an a10 counter with the ops
actual name
and in this case uh we have 232
probably once per step that
some op that needs to be lower in xla
and once you
iron those issues out the pro the code
will run much faster and will be very
performant
uh now so far we have seen how training
works on a cloud tp device
now let's discuss how to take it to the
next level
um and train on a cloud tp pod
as uh pods were described by vibhav
earlier
they consist of several devices
connected with very fast network and in
this
in the pytorch xla context we create
uh as many user vms as the cloud tp
devices
not cores so for example if you want to
train on a v3 332 32 course we would
need to create four vms
to to drive the training and we wrap
these user vms in an instance group so
everything needs to be in an instance
group and once we have set up these
resources
launching the training distributed mode
is very easy
now let's look at the command to do that
here the white
part of the large command is the actual
command that you were running to run on
one device so this is your code
with arguments and all you need to do to
scale it up to a pod level is is just
prefix the command with with these
elements
and here the green part is xladist
it's offered by torch xla and it
coordinates the resources
talks sets up the mesh between the
instance group and the tpus
and sets up the environment variables
specified by the next uh
set of elements uh for example the tpu
name the conda environment and any other
environment
variable that you might want to set up
and that's it
um it's there's really no code changes
uh
one gotcha here is uh the code needs to
be written
so that the data is sharded across all
the cores
uh otherwise um the
vms will end up doing the same work
unnecessary work
but that that's really the only gotcha
and scaling up is
is as easy as just prefixing your
command
so now let's look at some of the models
um that actually
have been tested and known to work uh
for in the computer vision uh area uh we
have resnet and resnecks and along with
most storage vision models such as
mobilenet and others
uh that already work in the nlp area we
have
transformers network uh for example fair
seeks transformer roberta
or hugging faces transformers we have a
working implementation of a deep
convolutional
again that's up on our github
and in the speech recognition world we
have
worked with uh fair six wave to wek and
vector quantized
vape tobacco let me note here that the
models that work on torch xl aren't
limited to these
these have been tested but
people have run other workloads and
other models
successfully as well and you can import
your model as well
to get started here are some resources
so
these are some of the tutorials that are
offered offered on google cloud web
pages
and it covers some of the models that i
just discussed in a previous slide
and along with the google cloud
tutorials there are
kaggle kernels from some of the kaggle
experts in the community
that they have successfully run uh
competitions on torch xla and they offer
their kernels
to the users and finally here's a
summary slide
of all the resources that we saw um
some of the github repositories that are
relevant to the project official
tutorials kaggle kernels
and please visit pytorch xla it's a very
active
open source library and
open issues if you encounter any issues
etc
thanks for listening